um when you stagger lubu because when
you stagger them you do like uh
something called a fatal blow where you
pretty much stab them and do like a huge
amount of the damage first off that
damage is pretty much half what you do
to anyone else second off when you
stagger him the first time he just gets
thrown off his horse you don't get to do
it the honor of fighting blue boy
he fights you on foot right and you have
to stagger him again to do massive
damage too and it's like I said it's not
even massive damage and then guess what
after you may have staggered him one
time on foot dude jumps back up in the
air gets back on his horse and keep in
mind during this entire time his horse
is running around in a circle on the
battlefield and there'll be times where
you'll you'll be fighting him and you
because I said in the in the tips to
fight him be very conscious where that
damn horses
doing when he running around you'll be
fighting him